And the answer is that these three, the ones that I've checked off, are parallel
to y equals 4x minus 5. We can see this by doing a little bit of rearranging so
we get each of these equations in the form y equals mx plus b. If we add y to
both sides of this equation, we can rearrange this equation so that instead it
reads y equals 4x. This one is already written in slope-intercept form, and we
can see that it's slope is, in fact, 4. Just like that of our original line. If
we divide both sides of this equation by 2, we end up with y equals 4x minus
one-half. Here, m is the same as in this equation. For each of these lines,
however, which are not parallel to this equation, in order to get y by itself,
we would have to divide both sides by 2. This would change the coefficient in
front of the x that it's no longer 4, which means that the slope of this line is
actually 2. The same thing would happen for this equation. So, this is the
perfect example of how sometimes, even if the coefficient in front of x, makes
it look like a line could be parallel to another line. We have to make sure that
the equation is actually in slope intercept form before we can make assumptions
about that.